a class works great when you want to
produce a fleet of similar objects as
with the target code in this run J s
example but what if you wanted a second
category of objects that was vaguely
similar to this car category maybe you
decide that in addition to enemy vans
your game also needs cop cars that can
be called to the player's aide so you
decide that cops would behave pretty
similarly to vams but they'd have a few
important differences you probably need
to refactor this code so that the cops
can behave a little bit differently so
imagine Cal is going to be one of these
cops the cow object ought to have all
the same vehicular powers as the other
two cars did what function could you use
to build this object